the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I'm using a few things here right I'm
using the fact that KL is non-negative
but KL is equal to 0 when I take twice
the same argument so I know that this
function is always non-negative and
that's so that's theta and that's KL P
theta star P theta and I know that at
theta star its equal to 0 ok I could be
in the case where I have this happening
I have to let's call it theta star Prime
I have to minimizer's that could be the
case right I'm not saying that so key of
L K L is 0 at the minimum that doesn't
mean that I have a unique minimum right
but it does actually what do I need to
use to make sure that I have only one
minimum so the definiteness is
guaranteeing to me that the unique
minute there's a unique piece data
stored that minimizes it but then I need
to make sure that there's a unique from
this unique piece data star I need to go
I need to make sure there's a unique
data store that defines this piece to
the star exactly
all right so I combined definiteness and
identifiability to make sure that
there's a unique minimizer in this case
cannot exist ok so basically let me
write what I just said
so definiteness that implies
that P theta star is the unique
minimizer of P theta maps to K L P theta
star P theta
alright so definiteness only guarantees
that the parabola distribution is
uniquely identified and identifiability
implies that theta star is the unique
minimizer of theta maps to KL P theta
star P theta okay
so I'm basically doing the composition
of two injective functions the first one
is the one that map's say theta to P
theta and the second one is the one that
map's P theta to the set of minimizer's
okay agree so at least morally you
should have agree that theta star is the
minimizer of this thing whether it's
unique or not you should agree that it's
a good one so maybe you can think it a
little longer on this and so thinking
about this being the minimizer then it
says well if I actually had a good
estimate for this function I would use
the strategy that I described for the
toe variation which is well I don't know
what this function looks like it depends
on theta star but maybe I can find an
estimator of this function that
fluctuates around this function and such
that when I minimize this estimator of
the function
I'm actually not too far okay and this
is exactly what drives me to do this
because I can actually construct an
estimator I can actually construct an
estimator such that this estimator is
actually of K of the key L is actually
close to the key oh all right so I
define key L hat
all right so all we did is just
replacing expectations respect to see
the star by averages that's what we did
so if you're a little puzzled by this
arrow that's all it says replace this
guy by this guy there's no mathematical
meaning it just means just replace it by
and now that actually gives tells me how
to get my estimator it just says well my
steamy Tarkio hat is equal to some
constant which I don't know I mean it
certainly depends on theta star but I
won't care about it when I'm trying to
minimize minus 1 over n sum from I to 1
to n log PF theta say of X right so here
I'm writing it with the density you have
it with the PMF on the slides and so you
have the two versions in front of you
okay I'm sorry I forgot the X I now
clearly this function I know how to
compute if you give me a theta since I
know the fam the the the form of the
density as theta for each theater that
you give me I can actually compute this
quantity right this I don't know but I
don't care because I'm just shifting the
value of the function I'm trying to
minimize the set of minimizer's it's not
going to change right so now this is my
estimation strategy minimize in theta
kiyo hat p theta star t theta okay
so now let's just make sure that we all
agree that so what we want is the
argument of the minimum right orgman
means the theta that minimizes this guy
well and finding the value of the
minimum okay so I'm trying to find the
argument of this thing well this is
equivalent to finding the orgman of say
a constant minus 1 over n sum from i who
want to end the vlog
that's theta X I okay so that's just I
think it likes me okay so so that's
minimizing this average right I just
plugged in the definition of kale hat
now I claim that taking the arming of a
constant or the argument plus a function
or the argument of the function is the
same thing is anybody not comfortable
with this idea okay so this is the same
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way this I should probably switch
to the next slide because I'm writing
the same thing but better and it's with
a PMF rather than as a PDF
okay now argument of the minimum is the
same about max sorry argument of the
negative thing is the same as our max
without the negative right our max over
theta of 1 over N sum from 1 equal to I
equal 1 to n log F theta of X I
taking the orgmen of the average or the
army of the some again it's not gonna
make much difference
just adding constants or multiplying by
constants does not change the argument
or the arc max now I have the sum of
logs which is the log of the product
okay that's the arc max of the log of f
theta of X 1 times F theta of X 2 F
theta of X n but the log is a function
that's increasing so maximizing log of a
function or maximizing the function
itself is the same thing the value is
going to change but the arc max is not
going to change everybody agrees with
this so this is equivalent to arc max
over theta of Pi from 1 to N of F theta
X I and that's because X maps to log X
is increasing okay so now I've gone from
minimizing the KL to minimizing the
estimate of the KO to maximizing this
product well this chapter is called
maximum likelihood estimation that's the
maximum comes from the fact that our
original idea was to minimize the
negative of a function so that's why
it's maximum likelihood and this
function here is called the likelihood
all right this function is really just
telling me they call it likelihood
because it's some measure of how likely
it is that data was the parameter that
generated the data okay so let's go to
the well we'll go to the formal
definition in a second but actually
energies could give you an intuition as
to why this is the distribution of the
day
okay-y this is the likelihood sorry why
is this making sense as a measure of
likelihood let's now think for
simplicity of the following model so I
have I'm on the real line and I look at
n say theta 1 for theta in the real do
you see that okay probably you don't
care ok so ok let's look at a simple
example so here's the model as I said
we're looking at observations on the
real line and they're distributed
according to some n 0 sorry theta 1 so I
don't care about the variance I know
it's 1 and it's indexed by theta in the
real line ok so this is the only thing I
need to figure out is what is the
density what is the mean of those guys
ok now I have this n observation then if
you actually remember from your
probability class you are you familiar
with the concept of joint density right
if I have multivariate observations the
joint density of independent random
variables is just a product of their
individual densities all right so really
when I look at the product from one I
could want to end of F theta of X I this
is really the joint density of the
vector well let me not use the word
vector of X 1 X n ok so if I take the
product of densities it's still a
density and it's actually the but this
time on the R to the N ok and so now
what this thing is telling me so think
of it in r2 right so this is the joint
density of two Gaussian so it's
something that looks like some
bell-shaped curve than two dimensions
and it's centered at the value
theta theta okay they both have them in
data so let's assume for one second it's
gonna be hard for me to make pictures in
n dimensions actually already in two
dimensions I can promise you that it's
not very easy so I'm actually just gonna
assume that n is equal to one for the
sake of illustration okay so now I have
this data and now I have one observation
okay and I know that the F theta looks
like this and what I'm doing is I'm
actually looking at the value of F X
theta at my observation go it x1 now
when I'm my principal tells me just find
the theta that makes this guy the most
likely what is the likelihood of my x1
well it's just the value of the function
right that's this value here and if I
wanted to make to find the most likely
theta that had generated this x1 what I
would need to do is to shift this thing
and put it here
okay and so my estimate make maximum
likelihood estimator here would be X
theta is equal to x1 okay that would be
just the observation because you know if
I have only in one observation what else
am I gonna do okay and so it sort of
makes sense and if you have more
observations you can think of it this
way as if you had more observations so
now I have say key observations or n
observations and what I do is that I
look at the value for each of these guys
right so this value this value this
value this value I take your product and
I make this thing large okay why do I
take the product well because I'm trying
to maximize their value altogether and I
need to just turn it into one number
that I can maximize and taking the
product is the natural way of doing it
either by motivating it by the KL
principle or motivating it by maximizing
the joint density rather than just
maximizing anything okay so that's
that's why you know visually this is the
maximum likelihood it just says that if
my observations are here then this guy
this mean data is more likely than this
guy
because now if I look at the value
of the function for these guys if I look
at data being this thing then this is a
very small value very small value very
small value very small value everything
gets a super small value right that's
just the value that it gets in the tail
here which is very close to zero but as
soon as I start covering all my points
with my bell-shaped curve then all the
values go up alright so I just want to
make a short break into statistics and
just make sure that the maximum likely a
principal involves maximizing a function
all right so I just want to make sure
that we're all in part about how do we
maximize functions okay
in most instances is going to be a
one-dimensional function because theta
is going to be a one dimensional
parameter like here it's the real line
so it's gonna be easy in some cases it
might be a multivariate function and
might be more complicated okay so let's
just make this interlude so the first
thing I want you to notice is that if
you open any book on what's called
optimization which basically is the
science behind optimizing functions you
will talk mostly I mean I'd say 99.9% of
the cases will talk about minimizing
functions but it doesn't matter because
you can just flip the function and you
just put a minus sign and minimizing H
is the same as maximizing minus H and
the opposite okay
so for this class since we're only going
to talk about maximum likelihood
estimation we will talk about maximizing
functions but don't be lost if you
decide certainly to open a book on
optimization and find only something
about minimizing functions okay so
maximizing and our Batory
function it can actually be fairly
difficult if I give you a function that
has this weird shape right let's think
of this polynomial for example and I
wanted to find the maximum how would you
do it so what is the thing you've
learned in calculus on how to maximize a
function to set the derivative equal to
zero maybe you want to check the second
derivative to make sure it's a maximum
and not a minimum but the thing is this
is only guaranteeing to you that you
have a local one right so if I do it for
this function for example then this guy
is going to satisfy this criterion this
guy is gonna satisfy this criterion this
guy is going to satisfy this criterion
this guy here and this guy satisfies the
criterion but
the second derivative one okay so I have
a lot of candidates and if my function
is can be really anything it's going to
be difficult whether it's analytically
by taking derivatives and setting them
to zero or trying to find some
algorithms to do this because if my
function is very jittery then my
algorithm basically has to check all
candidates and if there's a lot of them
and might take forever okay so this is
you know I have only one two three four
five candidates to check but in practice
you might have a million of them to
check and that might take forever
okay so what's nice about statistical
models and one of the thing that makes
all these models particularly you know
robust and that we still talk about them
a hundred years after they've been
introduced is that the functions that
the likelihoods that they lead for us to
maximize are actually very simple and
they all share a nice property which is
that of being concave all right so what
is a concave function well by definition
is just a function for which if let's
think of it as being twice
differentiable you can define functions
that are not differentiable as being
concave but let's think about it as
having a second derivative and so if you
look at the function that has the second
derivative concave is are the functions
they have their second derivative that's
equal that's negative everywhere not
just at the maximum everywhere okay and
so if strictly concave if this second
derivative actually strictly less than
zero okay so in particularly if I think
of a linear function y is equal to X
then this sunk this function has its
second derivative which is equal to zero
okay so it is concave but it's not
strictly concave okay now if I look at
the function which is negative x squared
what is its second derivative minus two
so it's strictly negative everywhere
okay so actually this is a pretty
canonical example of canonical of trig a
concave function if you want to think of
a picture of a strictly concave function
think of negative x square so parabola
pointing towards putting downwards okay
so we can talk about strictly convex
function so convex is just happening
when
negative of the function is concave so
that translate into having a secondary
which is either non negative or positive
depending on whether you talk about
convexity or strict convexity
but again we're those those convex
functions will are convenient when
you're trying to minimize something and
since we're trying to maximize the
function we're looking for concave so
here are some examples let's just go
through them quickly
okay so the first one is so here I made
my life a little uneasy by you know
talking about functions in theta right
I'm talking about likelihoods right so
I'm thinking of functions where the
parameter is theta so I have H of theta
and so if I start with theta squared
negative theta squared then as we said
theta H prime prime of theta and the
second derivative is minus 2 which
implies which is strictly negative so
this function is strictly concave okay
another function is H of theta which is
what did we pick square root of theta
what is the first derivative 1 over 2
square theta what is the second
derivative so that's theta to the
negative 1/2 so I'm just picking up
another negative 1/2 so I get negative
1/4 and then I get theta to the 3/4
downstairs ok sorry 3 halves
and that's strictly negative for theta
say larger than zero and I really need
to have this thing larger than zero so
that it's well defined but strictly
larger than zero is so that this thing
does not blow up to infinity and it's
true if you think about this function it
looks like this and already the first
derivative is going to zero to infinity
at zero and it's a concave function okay
another one is the log of course what is
the derivative of the log that's 1 over
theta sorry H prime of theta is 1 over
theta and the second derivative
- negative 1 over theta squared which
again is negative if theta is strictly
positive here I define it a straight I
don't need to define it to be strictly
positive here but I need it for the log
ok and fine ok so let's just do one more
right so H of theta is sine of theta but
here I take it only on an interval
because right so I said you want to
think of this function as pointing
always downwards and in particular you
don't want this function to have an
inflection point you don't want it to go
down and then up and then down and then
up because this is not concave and so
sine is certainly going up and down
right so what we do is we restrict it to
an interval where sine is actually so
with a site the sine function look like
at 0 at 0 then it's going up where is
the maximum the first maximum of the
sine I'm sorry PI over 2 where it takes
value 1 and then it goes down again and
then that's at PI and then I go down
again and here you see I actually start
changing my inflection so what we do is
we stop it at PI ok and look at this
function it certainly looks like a
parabola pointing downwards and so if
you look at the you can check that it
actually works with the derivative so
the derivative of sine
is cosine and the derivative of cosine
is negative sine okay and this thing
between zero and pi is actually positive
so this entire thing is gonna be
negative okay and you know I can come up
with a lot of examples but let's just
stick to those there's a linear function
of course I mean it and the fine
function is going to be concave but it's
actually going to be convex as well
which means that it's certainly not
gonna be strictly concave or convex okay
so d here's your standard picture and
here if you look at the dotted line what
it tells me is that a concave function
and the property we're going to be using
is that if a strictly concave function
as a maximum which is not always the
case but if it has a maximum then that's
it's actually must be sorry local
maximum it must be a global maximum
okay so just the fact that it goes up
and down and not again means that
there's only global Maxima that can
exist now if you look for example at the
square root function if I look at the
entire positive real line then this
thing is never gonna attain a maximum
it's just going to infinity as X goes to
infinity so if I wanted to find a
maximum I would have to stop somewhere
and say that the maximum is attained at
the right-hand side okay so that's the
beauty about convex functions or concave
functions is that essentially this
functions are easy to maximize and if
you if I tell you a function is concave
you take the first derivative set it
equal to zero if you find a point that
satisfies this then it must be a global
maximum okay yeah
so you won't get them so you want the
function to be concave on what on the
Union of the under on the convex all of
the intervals oh you want it to be okay
okay okay okay you're right so maybe the
definition so you're pointing to a
weakness in the definition let's just
say that theta is a convex set and then
you're good okay so you're right if
theta is not so yeah since I can
actually just said that this is true
only for theta I can just take pieces of
concave functions right you can do this
and then on the next one I can do this
the next one I can do this and then I
would have a bunch of them but what I
want is that think of it as a global
function on some convex set you're right
so think of theta is being convex with
this guy an interval if it's a real line
okay so as I said for more generally so
we can actually define concave functions
more generally in higher dimensions and
that will be useful if theta has more
dimension it's not just one parameter
but several parameters and for that you
need to remind yourself of calculus two
and you have a generalization of the
notion of derivative which is called the
gradient which is basically a vector
where each coordinate is just the
partial derivative with respect to each
coordinate of theta and the Hessian is a
matrix which is essentially a
generalization of the second derivative
I denoted by nabla squared but you can
write it the way you want and so this
matrix here is taking as entry the
partial derivative second partial
derivative of H with respect to theta I
and theta J okay and so that's the IJ
entry who has never seen that
okay so now being concave here is
essentially generalizing the saying that
a vector is equal to zero well that's
just setting the vector sorry saying
that the first-order condition to say
that it's a maximum is going to be the
same saying that a function has a
gradient equal to zero is the same as
saying that it has that each of its
coordinates are equal to zero and that's
actually going to be a condition for a
global maximum here but so to check
convexity we need to see that our matrix
itself is negative sorry to check
concavity we need to check the remai
tricks is negative and there is a notion
among matrices that compare matrix to
zero and that's exactly this notion you
pre and post multiply by the same X so
that works for symmetric matrices and
which is the case here and so you pre
multiply by X post multiply by the same
X oh right so you have your matrix your
hash in here
it's a D by D matrix if you have a D
dimensional matrix so let's call it okay
and then here I pre multiply by X
transpose I pull smalt apply by X and
this has to be non positive if I want it
to be concave and strictly negative if I
want it to be strictly concave okay
that's just a real generalization you
can check for yourself that this is the
same thing if I were in dimension 1 this
would be the same thing why because in
dimension 1 pre and post multiplying by
X is the same as multiplying by x
squared because in dimension 1 I can
just move my x's around right and so
that would just mean the first condition
would mean in dimension 1 that the
second derivative times X square has to
be none has to be less than or equal to
0 so here I need this for all X's that
are not 0 because I can take X to be 0
and make this equal to 0 right so this
is for X's that are not equal to 0 okay
and so some examples just look at this
function so now I have functions that
depend on two parameters theta 1 and
theta 2 so the first one is so if I take
theta to be equal to now I need two
parameters R squared and I look at the
function which is H of theta can
somebody tell me what H of theta is
minus 2 theta 2 squared
okay so let's compute the gradient of H
of theta ok so it's gonna be something
that has two coordinates to get the
first coordinate what do I do well I
take the derivative with respect to
theta I want thinking of theta 2 as
being a constant so this thing is going
to go away and so I get negative 2 theta
1 and when I take the derivative with
respect to the second part thinking of
this part is being constant I get minus
4 theta 2 okay
is that clear for everyone that's just
the definition of partial derivatives
and then if I want to do the Hessian so
now I'm gonna get a two by two matrix
the first guy here I take the first so
this guy I get by taking the derivative
of this guy respect to theta one so
that's easy so that's just minus two
this guy I get by taking derivative this
guy with respect to theta two
so I get what zero I treat this guy as
being a constant this guy is also going
to be zero because I take the derivative
of this guy with respect to theta one
and then I take the derivative of this
guy with respect to theta 2 so I get
minus four okay so now I want to check
that this function that this matrix
satisfies X transpose this matrix X is
negative so what I do is so what is X
transpose X so if I do X transpose Delta
squared H theta for X what I get is
minus two x one squared minus four X 2
squared okay because this matrix is
diagonal so all it does it just waits
the square of the X's so this guy is
definitely negative this guy is negative
and actually if if one of the two is
nonzero which means that X is nonzero
then this thing is actually strictly
negative so this function is actually
strictly concave okay and it looks like
a parabola that's slightly distorted in
one direction okay
so well I mean I know this might have
been some time ago maybe for some of you
might have been since high school so
just remind yourself of doing second
derivatives and Hessians and things like
this here's another one as an exercise H
is minus theta 1 minus theta 2 squared
so this one is going to actually not be
is actually not gonna be diagonal the
Hessian is not gonna be diagonal
who would like to do this now in class
ok thank you this is not a calculus
class so you can just do it as a
calculus exercise and you can do it for
log as well now there is a nice recipe
for concavity that works for for the
second one and the third one and the
thing is if you look at those particular
functions what I'm doing is I'm taking
first of all a linear combination of my
arguments and then I take a concave
function of this guy and this is always
gonna work this is always gonna give me
a concave function so the computations
that just made I actually never made
them when I prepared those slides
because I don't have to I know that if I
take a linear combination of those
things and then I take a concave
function of this guy I'm always gonna
get a concave function okay so that's an
easy way to to check this or at least
you you know at least as a sanity check
all right and so as I said finding
maximizers of concave or strictly
concave function is the same as it was
in the one-dimensional case what I do
sorry so in the one-dimensional case we
just agreed that we just think they're
better than set it to zero in the higher
dimensional case we take the gradient
and set it equal to zero again that's
calculus all right so it turns out that
so this is going to give me equations
right the first one is an equation in
theta the second one is an equation in
theta 1 theta 2 theta 3 all the way to
theta D and it doesn't mean that because
I can write this equation that I can
actually solve it by this equation might
be super nasty might be like I don't
know some polynomial in Exponential's
and logs equals
or some crazy thing and so the the
there's actually four concave function
since we know there's a unique Maximizer
there's this theory of concave convex
optimization which really since those
books are talking about minimizing you
had to find some sort of direction but
you can think of it as the theory of
concave maximization and they allow you
to find algorithms to solve this
numerically and fairly efficiently okay
that means fast even if DS of size
10,000 you're gonna wait for one second
is gonna tell you what the maximum is
okay and that's what machine learning is
about if you've taken any class on
machine learning there's a lot of
optimization because they have really
really big problems to solve often in
this class since this is more
introductory statistics we will have a
closed form for the maximum likelihood
estimator will be saying theta hat
equals and say X bar and that will be a
maximum likelihood estimator
okay so just why I just so has anybody
seen convex optimization before so let
me just give you an intuition why those
functions are easy to maximize or to
minimize in one dimension it's actually
very easy for you two to see that and
the reason is this if I want to maximize
the concave function what I need to do
is to be able to query a point and get
as an answer the derivative of this
function okay so now let's say this is
the function I want to optimize and I've
been running my algorithm for you know
10 5/10 of a second and it's at this
point here okay that's the candidate now
what I can ask is what is the derivative
of my function here well it's gonna give
me a value and this value is going to be
either negative positive or zero well if
it's zero that's great that means I'm
here and I can just go home I've solved
my problem okay I know there's a unique
maximum and that's what I want to find
if it's positive it actually tells me
that I'm on the left of the optimizer
right then I'm not the left of the
optimum
value and if it's negative it means that
I'm at the right of the value I'm
looking for and so most of the convex
optimization methods basically tell you
well if you queried the derivative and
it's actually positive move to the right
and if it's negative move to the left
now by how much you move is basically
well why people write books and in
higher dimension it's a little more
complicated all right because in higher
dimension thinks about two dimensions
then I'm actually the I'm only being
able to again to get a vector and the
vector is only telling me well here is
half of the space in which you can move
now here if you tell me move to the
right I know exactly which direction I'm
gonna have to move but in two dimension
you're gonna basically tell me well move
in this global direction and so of
course I know there's a line on the
floor I cannot move behind but even if
you tell me draw a line on the floor and
move only to that side of the line then
there's many direction in that line that
I can go to and that's also why there's
lots of things you can do in
optimization okay but still this putting
this line on the floor is telling me do
not go backwards and that's very
important it's just telling you which
direction I should be going
always okay all right so and that's
what's behind this notion of gradient
descent algorithm a steepest descent or
steepest descent actually for trying to
maximize okay so let's move on so this
course is not about optimization all
right so as I said the likelihood was
this guy the product of F of the Excise
and one way you can do this is just
basically the Joint Distribution of my
data at the point data so now the
likelihood formally so here I'm giving
myself a model II P theta and here I'm
going to assume that E is discrete so
that I can talk about pmf's but
everything you're doing just redo it for
the sake of yourself by replacing pmf's
by PDF so never
it's gonna be fine we'll do it in a
second all right so the likelihood of
the model so here I'm not looking at the
likelihood of a parameter I'm looking at
the likelihood of a model so it's
actually a function of the parameter and
actually I'm gonna make it even a
function of the points x1 to xn all
right so I have a function and what it
takes as input is all the points x1 to
xn and a parameter a candidate parameter
theta not the true one a candidate okay
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
look at the probability that my random
variables under this distribution p
theta take this exact values px 1 PX 2px
now remember if my data was independent
then I could actually just say that the
probability of this intersection is just
a product of the probabilities and it
would look like something like this but
I can define likelihood even if I don't
have independent random variables but
think of them as being independent
because that's what we're gonna
encounter in this class okay I just want
you to be aware that if I had dependent
variables I could still define the
likelihood I would have to understand
how to compute this probabilities though
to be able to compute it okay so think
of Bernoulli's for example okay so
here's my example of a bernly I have so
my parameter is so my model is 0-1
Bernal a P P is in the interval 0 1 ok
the probability just as a side remark
I'm just gonna use the fact that I can
actually write the PMF of a bernal in a
very concise form right if I ask you
what the PMF of a Bernoulli is you could
tell me well the probability that X so
under P the probably that X is equal to
0 is 1 minus P the probability under P
that X is equal to 1 is equal to P but I
can be a bit smart and say that for any
X that's either 0 or 1 the probability
under P that X is equal to little X I
can write it in a compact form
as P to the X 1 minus P to the 1 minus X
and you can check that this is the right
form because well you have to check it
only for two values of X 0 and 1 and if
you plug in 1 you only keep the P if you
plug in 0 you only keep the 1 minus P
and that's just a trick okay I could
have gone with many other ways agreed I
could have said actually something like
[Music]
another one would be which we're not
going to use but we could say well it's
X P plus 1 minus X 1 minus P right
that's another one but this one is going
to be convenient okay so forget about
this guy for a second alright so now I
said that the likelihood is just this
function that's computing the
probability that X 1 is equal to little
X 1 so likelihood is L of X 1 X and so
let me try to make those calligraphic so
you know that I'm talking about smaller
values right
a small X's X 1 xn and then of course P
sometimes we even put I didn't do it but
sometimes you can actually put a semi
column here same icon so you know that
those two things are treated differently
and so now you have this thing is equal
to what well is just the probability
under P that X 1 is little X 1 all the
way to X n is little like sin
okay that's just the definition
all right so now let's start working so
we write the definition and then we want
to make it look like something we would
potentially be able to maximize if I
were like if I take the derivative of
this with respect to peace that very
helpful because I just don't know okay
just one day algebraic function of P
okay so this thing is going to be equal
to what well what is the first thing I
want to use I have a probability of an
intersection of events so it's just the
product of the probabilities so this is
the product from one I equal one to n of
P small p X I is equal to little X I all
right that's independence okay now I'm
starting to be in business because for
each P we have a closed form right I
wrote this as this supposedly convenient
form I still have to reveal to you why
it's convenient so this thing is equal
to well we said that that was p x i
sorry little like sy 1 minus p to the 1
minus x i okay so that was just what i
wrote over there that's the probability
that X I is equal to little X I and
since they all have the same parameter P
I just have this P that shows up here
okay and so now I'm just taking the
products of something to the X I so it's
this thing to the sum of the x i's
everybody agrees with this so this is
equal to P sum of the X I 1 minus P to
the N minus sum of the X I
okay if you don't feel comfortable with
writing it directly you can observe that
this thing here is actually equal to P
over 1 minus P to the X I times 1 minus
P okay so now when I take the product
I'm getting the products of those
geysers just to the this guy to the
power some and this guy to the power N
and then I can rewrite it like this if I
want okay and so now well that's what we
have here and now I'm in business
because I can still hope to maximize
this function alright and how do I
maximize this function well I have to do
is to take the derivative do you want to
do it let's just take the derivative
okay oh sorry I didn't tell you that the
well the maximum like to the principle
is to just maximum with the idea is to
maximize this thing okay but I'm not
gonna get there right now okay so let's
do it maybe for the Poisson model for a
second so if you want to do it for the
Poisson model
[Applause]
so let's write the likelihood right so
right now I'm not doing anything I'm not
maximizing I'm just computing it the
likelihood function okay so the
likelihood function for quest on so now
I know what is my sample space for
personal part of it positive integers
and well lets me write it like this
twice so lambda and I'm gonna take
lambda to be positive and so that means
that the probability that under lambda
that X is equal to little X in the
sample space is lambda to the x over
factorial X e to the minus lambda so
that's basically the same as the compact
form that I wrote over there
it's just now different one and so what
I want to write my likelihood again we
said little X's this is equal to what
well it's equal to the probability under
lambda that x1 is little X 1 X n is
little X n which is equal to the product
okay just by independence and now I can
write those guys as being each of them
being equal 1 to N so this guy is just
this thing where I plug in X I so I get
lambda to the X I divided by factorial X
I times e to the minus lambda ok and now
I mean this guy is gonna be nice this
guy it's not gonna be too nice let's
write it what I'm gonna take the product
of those guys here I'm gonna pick a plum
de to the sum of the x i's here I'm
gonna pick up exponential minus n times
lambda and here I'm going to pick up
just the product of the factor
so x1 factorial all the way to X n
factorial then I get lambda the sum of
the X I sorry those are little exercise
e to the minus s and lambda okay so that
might be freaky at this point but
remember this is a function we will be
maximizing and the denominator here does
not depend on lambda so we knew that
maximizing this function with this
denominator or any other denominator
including one will give me the same arc
max so it won't be a problem for me
as long as it does not depend on lambda
this thing is gonna go away okay so in
the continuous case the likelihood I
cannot write so if I would write the
likelihood like this in the continuous
case this one would be equal to what 0
right so it's not very helpful and so
what we do is we define the likelihood
as the product of the f of theta X I now
that would be a jump if I told you well
just define it like that and go home and
don't discuss it but we know that this
is exactly what's coming from the well
actually I think I erased it it was just
behind so it this was exactly what was
coming from the KL divergence estimated
right the thing that I showed you if we
want to follow this strategy which
consists in estimating the KL divergence
and minimizing it is exactly doing this
alright so in the gaussian case well
let's write it so in the gaussian case
let's see what the likelihood looks like
okay so if I have a Gaussian experiment
here did I actually write it okay so I'm
gonna write I'm gonna take mu and Sigma
as being two parameters so that means
that my sample space is gonna be what
well my sample space is still are all
right those are just my observations but
then I'm gonna have n Mu Sigma squared
and the parameters of interest are mu in
R and Sigma squared and say zero
infinity okay so that's my Gaussian
model yes no there's no I mean there's
no difference yeah I think the all the
slides I put the curly bracket and I'm
just being lazy I just like those
concave parentheses all right so so
let's write it so the definition L x1 X
N and now I have two parameters mu and
Sigma squared we said by definition is
the product from I equal 1 to N of F
theta of a little X I now think about it
here we always had an extra line right
the line was to say that the definition
was the probability that they were all
equal to each other
that was the joint probability and here
I could actually have a line that says
it's the joint probability distribution
of the x i's and if it's not independent
it's not gonna be the product but again
since we're only dealing with the
dependent observations in the scope of
this class this is the only definition
we're gonna be using ok and actually
from here on I will literally skip this
this step when I when I talk about
discrete ones as well because they're
also independent agreed so we start with
this which we agreed was the definition
for this particular case and so
all of you know by heart with the
density of a sorry that's not data I
should write it mu sigma squared and so
you need you need to understand what
this density is and it's prob for a
product of 1 over Sigma square root 2 pi
times exponential minus X I minus mu
squared divided by 2 Sigma squared ok
that's the Gaussian density with
parameters mu and Sigma squared I just
plugged in this thing which I don't give
you so you just have to trust me it's
all over any book certainly I mean you
can find it you I will give it to you
and again you're not expected to know it
by heart though if you do your homework
every week without wanting to you will
definitely use some of your brain to
remember that thing ok and so now well I
have a I have this constant in front
right 1 over Sigma square root 2 pi that
can pull out so I get 1 over Sigma
square root 2 pi the power N and then I
have the product of Exponential's which
we know is the exponential of the sum so
this is equal to exponential minus and
here I'm going to put the 1 over 2 Sigma
squared outside the sum
okay and so that's how this guy shows up
just a product of the density is
evaluated at respectively x1 to xn okay
any question about computing those
likelihoods yes oh that's a typo thank
you because I just took it from probably
the previous thing so those are actually
should be okay thank you for noting that
one
so this line should say for any X 1 to X
n in R to the N thank you good catch any
other question all right so that's
really a to the N right my sample space
always okay so what is maximum
likelihood estimation well again if you
go back to the estimate that we got the
estimation strategy which consisted in
replacing expectation with respect to
theta star by average of the data in the
KL divergence we would try to maximize
not this guy but this guy right the the
thing that we actually plugged in were
not any small exercise we're actually
the random variables capital X I so the
maximum likelihood estimator is actually
taking the likelihood which is a
function of little X's and now the
values at which it estimates it look at
it is actually the capital X is my data
so it looks at this function at at the
data and at the parameters theta that's
what the like so that's the first thing
and then the maximum likelihood
estimator is maximizing this okay so in
a way what it does is it's sort of it's
a function that couples together
the data capital X 1 to capital X n with
the parameter theta and just now tries
to maximize it
okay so just if this is just a little
hard for you to to get the likelihood is
formally defined as a function of X
right like when I write f of X f of
little X I define it like that but
really the only arguments at which the
only X arguments were going to evaluate
this function adds are always the random
variable which is the data so if you
want you can think of it as those guys
being not parameters of this function
but really random variables themselves
directly okay like this is it is there
any question so those are going to be
known once you have right so is it's
always the same thing in stats you first
design your estimator as a function of
random variables and then once you get
data you just plug it in but we want to
think of them as being random variables
because we're going to we want to
understand what the fluctuations are so
we're gonna keep them as random variable
for as long as we can we're gonna spit
out the estimator as a function of the
random variables and then when we want
to compute it from data we're just gonna
plug it in okay so keep the random
variables for as long as you can unless
I give you numbers actual numbers just
those are random variables okay so there
might be some confusion if you've seen
any stats class sometimes there's a
notation which says oh the realization
of the random variables are lowercase
versions of the original random
variables right so a lowercase X should
be thought as the realization of the
uppercase X this is not the case here
when I write this it's the same way as I
write f of X is equal to x squared right
it's just an argument of a function that
I want to define okay so those are just
generic X so if you correct the typo
that I have this should say that this
should be for any X in X I'm just
describing a function and now the only
place at which I'm interesting in
evaluating that function at least for
those first end arguments is at the
capital
observations random variables that I
have okay so there's actually texts
there's actually people doing research
on when does the maximum likelihood
estimator exist all right and that
happens when you have infinite sets X's
sorry infinite sets Thetas are or and
and this thing can divert there's no
global maximum there's crazy things that
might happen and so we're actually
always going to be in a case where this
maximum likelihood estimator exists and
if it doesn't then it means that you
actually need to restrict your parameter
space capital theta to something smaller
otherwise it won't exist okay so another
thing is the log likelihood estimator so
it is still the likelihood estimator we
solved for that maximizing a function or
maximizing log of this function is the
same thing because the log function is
increasing so the same thing is
maximizing a function or maximizing I
don't know exponential of this function
every time I take an increasing function
it's actually the same thing maximizing
a function or maximizing 10 times this
function is the same thing so the
function X maps to 10 times ax is
increasing and so the log why do we talk
about log likelihood rather than
likelihood so the log of likelihood is
really just I mean the log likelihood is
the log of the likelihood and the reason
is exactly for this kind of reasons
remember that was my likelihood right
and I want to maximize it and it turns
out that in stats there's a lot of of
distributions that look like exponential
of something so I I might as well just
remove the exponential by taking the log
okay so once I have this guy I can take
the log this is something to a power of
something if I take the log it's gonna
look better for me I have this thing
well I have another one somewhere I
think where I had the puesto whoever the
crystal the person was going so the
person was the same thing if I took the
log because I had a power that would
make my life easier so the log is not
doesn't have any particular intrinsic
notion except that it's just more
convenient now that being said if you
think about Max
amazing the KL the original formulation
but we actually removed the log right if
we come back to the KL thing where is my
key L sorry right that was maximizing
the sum of the logs of the PI's and so
then we worked at it by saying that the
sum of the logs was max this maximizing
the sum of the log was the same as
maximizing the product but here were
basically log-likelihood is just going
backwards in this chain of equivalent
suits and that's just because the
original formulation was already
convenient so we went to find the
likelihood and then coming back to our
original estimation strategy right so
look at the Poisson I want to take log
here to make my sum of excise go down
okay so this is my estimator so right so
the log of L so one thing that you want
to notice is that the log of L of X 1 X
n data as we said is equal to the sum
from I equal 1 to N of the log of either
p theta of X I or so that's in the
discrete case and in the continuous case
is the sum of the log of f theta of X I
okay
the beauty of this is that you don't
have to really understand the difference
between probability mass function and
probability distribution function to
implement this whatever you get that's
what you plug in okay any questions so
far
all right so shall we do some
computations and check that actually
we've introduced all this stuff
complicate functions maximizing KL
divergence a lot of things so that we
can spit out again averages alright
that's great we're gonna be able to
sleep at night and know that there's a
really powerful mechanism called maximum
likelihood estimator that was actually
driving and into our intuition without
us knowing okay so
let's do this so burn elite trials I
still have it over there okay so
actually I don't know what well let me
write it like that right so it's P over
1 minus P X I so sorry some of the
excise times 1 minus P to the N okay so
now I want to maximize this as a
function of P well the first thing we
would want to do is to check that this
function is concave and I'm just gonna
ask you to trust me on this so I don't
want sorry some of the excise I only
want to take the derivative and just go
home okay so let's just take the
derivative of this with respect to P
actually no this one was more convenient
I'm sorry
this one was slightly more convenient
okay so now we have let me call this
thing so now let me take the log okay so
if I take the log what I get is some of
the excise times log P plus n minus some
of the excise times log 1 minus P
okay now I take the derivative with
respect to P and set it equal to zero
okay so what does that give me it tells
me that some of the excise divided by P
minus n some of the X is divided by one
minus P is equal to zero
okay so now I need to solve for P so
let's just do it so what we get is that
1 minus P some of the excise is equal to
P and minus some of the excise so that's
P times n minus some of the excise plus
some of the excise so let me put it on
the right so that P times n is equal to
some of the excise and that's equivalent
to P actually I should start by putting
P hat from here on because I'm already
solving an equation right and so P hat
is equal to some of the excise divided
by n which is my xn bar okay well so
model as I said twice mu is gone okay so
let me rewrite it quickly
okay so Poisson the likelihood in x1 xn
and lambda was equal to lambda to the
sum of the X is e to the minus n lambda
divided by X 1 factorial all the way to
X n factorial so now let me take the log
likelihood that's gonna be equal to what
it's gonna tell me it's gonna be well
let me get rid of this guy first minus
log of X 1 factorial all the way to X n
factorial that's a constant with respect
to lambda so
I'm gonna take the derivative it's gonna
go and I'm gonna have plus some of the
excise Times log lined up and then I'm
gonna have minus and lambda okay so now
let me take the derivative and set it
equal to zero so log L partial with
respect to lambda of log L say lambda
equals zero this is equivalent to so
this guy goes this guy gives me some of
the X is divided by lambda hat equals n
and so that's equivalent to lambda hat
is equal to some of the X I divided by n
which is xn bar okay take derivative set
it equal to zero and just solve it's a
very satisfying exercise actually
especially when you get the average in
the end you don't have to think about it
forever
okay the Gaussian model I'm gonna leave
to you as an exercise okay take the log
to get rid of this pesky exponential and
then take the derivative and you should
be fine it's a bit more like it might be
one more line than those guys okay so
well actually you need to take the
gradient in this case don't check the
second derivative right now you don't
have to really think about it what do
you don't want to add yes when I have a
function that's concave and I'm on like
some infinite interval then it's true
that taking the derivative and setting
it equal to zero will give me the
maximum but again I might have a
function that looks like this now if I'm
on some finite interval let me go
elsewhere so if I'm on some finite
interval
and my function looks like this as a
function of theta let's say this is my
log likelihood as a function of theta
then okay there's no place in this
interval let's say this is between 0 & 1
there's no place in this interval where
the derivative is equal to 0 and if you
actually try to solve this you will find
a solution which is not in the interval
0 1 and that's actually how you know
that you probably should not take the
derivative equal to 0 so don't panic if
you get something that says well the
solution is that infinity right if this
function keeps going you will find that
the solution you won't be able to find a
solution
apart from infinity all right you're
gonna see something like 1 over theta
hat is equal to 0 or something like this
right so you know that when you found
this kind of solution you've probably
made a mistake at some point and the
reason is because the functions that are
like this you don't find the maximum by
setting the derivative equal to 0
you actually just find a maximum by
saying well it's an increasing function
on the interval 0 1 so the maximum must
be attained at 1 ok so here in this case
that would mean that my maximum would be
1 my estimator would be 1 which would be
word so typically here you have a
function of the x i's so one example
that you will see many times is when
this guy is the maximum of the x i's
okay and in which case the maximum is
attained here which is the maximum of
the Excite okay so just keep in mind
what I would recommend is every time
you're trying to take the maximum of a
function just try to plot the function
in your head it's not too complicated
those things are usually squares or
square roots or logs you know what those
functions look like just plot them in
your mind and make sure that you will
find a maximum which really goes up and
then down again if you don't then that
means your maximum is achieved achieved
at the boundary and that's you have to
think differently to get it okay so the
machinery that consistent setting the
equal to0 work say 80% of the time at
some time you have to be careful and
from the context it will be clear that
you had to be careful because you will
find some crazy stuff such as solve one
over theta hat is equal to zero okay all
right so before we conclude I just
wanted to give you some intuition about
how does the maximum likelihood perform
right so there's something called the
Fisher information that essentially
controls how this thing performs and the
Fisher information is essentially a
second derivative or Hessian so if I'm
in the one dimensional parameter case
it's a number it's a second derivative
if I'm in a multi dimensional case it's
actually a hessian it's a matrix okay so
I'm gonna actually take a notation
little you know curly L of theta to be
the log-likelihood okay and that's a log
likelihood for one observation let's
call it X generically but think of it as
being x1 for example and I don't care of
like summing because I'm actually going
to take expectation of this thing so
it's not going to be a data-driven
quantity I'm gonna play with okay so now
I'm going to assume that it is twice
differentiable almost surely because
it's a it's a random function and so now
I'm gonna just sweep under the rug some
you know technical conditions when this
thing's hold so typically when can i
permute integral and derivatives and you
know this kind of stuff that you don't
want to think about okay the rule of
thumb is it always works until it
doesn't in which case that probably
means you're actually solving some sort
of calculus problem because in practice
it just doesn't happen all right so the
information the Fisher information is
the expectations' of the what that's
called the outer product so that's the
product of this gradient and the
gradient transpose so that forms a
matrix right that's a matrix minus the
outer product of the expectations so
that's really what's called the
covariance matrix of this vector nabla
eval theta which is a random vector
because I'm forming the covariance
matrix of this thing and the technical
conditions tells me that actually this
guy which depends only on the Hessian is
actually equal to negative expectation
of the sorry depends on the gradient is
actually negative exponential
expectation of the Hessian so I can
actually get a quantity that depends on
the second derivatives only using first
derivatives but the expectation is gonna
play a role here and the fact that it's
a blog and lots of things actually show
up here and so in this case what I get
is that so in the one dimensional case
then this is just the covariance matrix
of a one dimensional thing which is just
the variance of itself so the variance
of the derivative is actually equal to
negative this expectation of the second
derivative okay so we'll see that next
time but what I wanted to emphasize with
this is that why do we care about this
quantity right that's called the Fisher
information Fisher is the founding
father of modern statistics why did we
give this quantity his name well it's
because this quantity is actually very
critical what is the second derivative
of a function tell me at the maximum
well it's telling me how how curved it
is right if I have a zero second
derivative and basically flat and if I
have a very high second derivative I'm
very curvy and when I'm very curvy what
it means is that very robust to the
estimation errors remember our
estimation strategy which consisted in
replacing expectation by averages if I'm
extremely curvy I can move a little bit
this thing the maximum is not going to
move much and this formula here so
forget about the matrix version for a
second is actually telling you exactly
this it's telling me the curvature is
basically the variance of this the first
derivative and so the more the first
derivative fluctuates the more your
maximum is actually our max is going to
move all over the place so this is
really controlling how flat your map
your likelihood your log likelihood is
at its maximum the flatter it is the
more sensitive to fluctuations er max is
going to be the curvier it is the less
sensitive it is and so what we're hoping
a good model is going to be one that has
a large
small value for the Fisher information I
want this to be small I want it to be
large right because this is the
curvature right this number is negative
its concave so if I take a negative sign
it's gonna be something that's positive
and the larger this thing the more curvy
it is oh yeah because it's the variance
okay I'm sorry this is what okay yeah
maybe I should not go into those details
because I'm actually out of time but
just spoiler alert
the asymptotic variance of your the
variance basically as n goes to infinity
of the maximum likelihood estimator is
going to be 1 over this guy so we want
it to be large because that what the
asymptotic variance is gonna be very
small
all right so we're out of time we'll see
that next week and I have your homework
with me and I will actually turn it in I
will give it to you outside so we can
leave let the other room
come in ok I'll just leave it up